[Music]
okay we got an opponent nick chen from
canada 1500 okay so this is our first
1500
we are once again playing
the basics the classics ooh king scam
but okay this is nice because i can
teach you guys
uh i can not teach you i can remind you
of my king's gambit system this is an
incredibly rare move
and it scores incredibly well and those
of you who've been on my stream for a
long time you might remember what this
move is i taught it to john davis the
joker the jkx got it you deserve a sub
c6
what the hell are we doing this looks
like the worst move in the position and
this is exactly the point
uh c6 is like the karo khan against the
king's game but now if you think about
why you even play c6 in the karo khan
well you do that in order to prepare d5
and that's the whole point we wait for
knight f3
and then we strike with d5 and hopefully
you can start to see the point if he
takes d5 we can push e4 and that's why
we waited for the knight to come to f3
now the actual objective evaluation of
c6 black is slightly worse but only if
white knows exactly how to play uh and
most of the time i end up getting better
positions with the black pieces
alright so what should we do now should
we take on e4 in this position
should we take on e4
what do you guys think and don't say no
just because i'm asking the question
i i know you're used to answering no to
you know that question but the answer is
yes of course we should because after d
takes c4d takes e4 we can trade queens
and force the king onto d1 which is an
incredibly undesirable square
the answer is yes we should take on d4
on e4
it's possible that he'll take on e5 with
the knight that's probably the best move
if d takes c4 happens that end game is
better for us that king on d1 is going
to be really vulnerable even though
there are no queens on the board yeah 95
is good
95 is good
all right so now uh of course f6 is
impossible because of queen h5 check
that's an important uh thing to note
we also shouldn't rush to take on d3 and
help white develop so we should try to
trade on our own terms
and we should do that while developing
our pieces
and so what move am i
sort of implying well i'm implying the
move knight f6 yeah developing and if he
wants to take on e4 be my guess you know
we'll trade queens and then recapture
with the knight you might say well
aren't we worried about the knight being
on e5 the 995 is annoying but what is it
actually doing is it really attacking
anything not really all right we'll deal
with the night later we'll go knight bd7
at some point okay knight c3
and we have several options for how we
can play we can take on d3 here
and then follow it up with the move
bishop c5
why is that good because that prevents
white from castling and it keeps the
king in the center we would love to go
bishop c5 immediately but we can't
because that gives up a pawn
the other approach here is to play
bishop b4 developing the bishop and
pinning the knight and taking the sting
out of d takes d4
i think both options are interesting
uh he takes d3 is the more concrete
approach to the position bishop b4 is
the more
positional approach where
well we'll probably end up taking his
knight on c3 and trying to damage his
pawn structure
i don't know let's play bishop before i
feel like we're playing more
positionally in the speed run
uh let's let's go with bishop before i'm
expecting a3 that's sort of the
uh
the instinctual response and a3 is maybe
even the best move in the position
fog bear is bad i mean the falco beer
counter gambit is one of the most
overrated
systems against
the king's game but it sounds cool but
it's actually just bad bishop d2 good
move
our opponent's playing well
okay um well this unpins the knight and
it reinforces the attack on e4 it
essentially forces us to trade on d3 but
now now that we've developed most of our
pieces we're fine taking on d3 because
we can castle on the next move
and my point is that this pawn on f4 is
in the long run going to be a weakness i
i think
in the short run it looks good it looks
like oh it supports tonight but in the
long run
uh once white castle's king side my
claim is that this pawn uh is going to
end up causing causing trouble for white
he's thinking i mean bishop takes d3 is
what i'm fully expecting yeah
now let's castle
and on the next move after he castles
we need to deal with the knight on e5 we
need to start well we need to try to
trade it ideally
and the way that we do that as i
indicated earlier is that we go knight b
to d7
all right and this is more important
than developing the bishop so i wouldn't
go bishop e6 i would immediately go
knight bd7 i would try to address the
question of the knight as quickly as
possible before he has a chance to fully
solidify it queen f3
man that's another very good move
all right well
um
i think that he wants to castle
he wants to castle queenside
he wants to castle queenside i don't
think that really changes what we do
though let's go knight pd7
all right so knight takes d7
yeah well obviously we should take with
the bishop because that at least
develops a piece
and the other thing about this that
is in our favor yeah so this is a
blunder and actually i've seen people
blunder like this all the time
just don't forget that when you castle
and you have a queen on f3 your rook and
your queen end up on the same diagonal
this is a very common blunder in many
different openings and obviously
it's skewer time bishop g4 we win the
exchange that doesn't end the game but
it's a massive
material win and essentially our
position is going to be winning after
that
common common blunder i think what
people forget is they don't really
visualize the position after they castle
uh and and and so this move is is really
easy
easy to overlook
okay queen g3
okay bishop takes d1
now the technical stage how do we
convert this advantage
well
we should try to make priorities as we
always do what have we not finished we
haven't finished getting our pieces into
the game and making surface level
improvements what am i talking about
what move am i implying
what what is a a low-hanging fruit kind
of move that we can play to improve our
position
well you guys are
are thinking about moving the queen but
we don't have to move the queen yet
there's two bishops on the d-file not
one when he moves the bishop from d2
then we can move our queen i don't need
to rush to move our queen yeah let's go
rookie a let's get our rook on an open
file
right so at this level right we're
hitting 1400 it's it's important as i
mentioned last time to be very concrete
and the reason i'm not afraid of
anything on the d-files because
you can't move two bishops at the same
time
uh just mathematically so nothing what
can happen to us as long as he keeps
both bishops on this file
obviously in my mind i'm telling myself
okay the moment this bishop moves
i'm
you know i'm making a mental note to not
forget to move my queen
as to where the queen can go it can go
to c7 that's a nice little square
it can go to a5 but it depends on where
he moves the bishop queen f3
okay
um well
again multiple approaches to this
position this is the kind of situation
where
it's less important
the actual move you make and more
important you know what's the general
approach that you're taking to the
position
in terms of the general approach well we
want to trade pieces that would be great
and there is a move that
initiates a bunch of trades
there is a move that that
is quite obvious i mean it's quite
straightforward and it offers
you know the trade of one but probably
even two minor pieces
yeah queen for queen d4 is possible but
that queen could end up getting pretty
vulnerable
yeah i'm thinking of the move knight t5
now what's important about this knight
takes d5 bishop takes d2 check
rook takes d2 obviously we don't want to
recapture with the queen because that
walks right into the discovery but we
can take with a pawn there and we if we
reach that moment we you'll see that we
have an even better move than pawn takes
d5
think about what that move might be in
the meantime
if y doesn't take on d5
now i think that some of you might be
worried about the h7 pawn becoming a
weakness right you might be worried
about queen h5 or queen h3 but those are
not worrisome because you can always
just play g6 you know white doesn't have
sufficient material on the king's side
to cause
true
problems to us white can threaten
checkmate but you should never just be
afraid of a mate threat
all right knight takes d5 yes we're
going down that line bishop takes c2
check
and after rook takes d2 another lesson
in the importance of not playing
automatically always looking for
a better a better move
okay he plays king takes d2 i mean he
probably saw
what would happen in the event of rook
takes two and that is rookie one check
that forces a rook trade
and then after that we could play queen
takes d5
what should we take with we can take
with either piece
uh but
you know in the interest of
playing more uh consecutively right we
we initiated this campaign to trade a
bunch of pieces
so i see no
point in
diverging from our general strategy
this is not going to be the easiest end
game to convert because white is quite
well coordinated we'll have a weak pawn
on d5 but we'll make it happen
you can pre-move c takes d5
okay queen h3 well that makes our job
easier i actually like the fact that the
queens are caps on the board now
that threatens h7 because pinned pieces
protect
now a question for you guys h6 or g6
doesn't matter
obviously both moves are fine but one
move is more accurate than the other
which one is more accurate
i talked about this previously when
you're making luft you got to be very
careful about what kind of loof you make
any time there's a bishop on d3 playing
h6
uh often doesn't accomplish the task of
making luft because the bishop controls
the h7 square therefore
i much prefer
to play
g6 and just shut down the bishop
entirely now am i not worried about
am i not worried about
weakening my dark squares well what's
going to occupy the dark squares black
white doesn't have a bishop
okay what now
well now um again we have multiple
approaches but we have a queen move
that's extremely nasty here
and the way that i found this is i i
understood that white is probably
intending king c1
so some of you i'm sure coming up with
the idea of pushing the apon down the
board that's good
but queen a5 is a great move that wins
the a pawn oh queen a5 is even better i
was going to propose queen d4
to hit the f4 pawn and be able to to aim
for a1 but no queen a5 check is
is superior
okay queen takes a two of my headphones
died all right i'll have to go without
them you won't hear the board sounds but
that's fine
yeah so
this idea of going a5 a4 is
good follow-up white is trying to create
to make stuff happen
now again
even before we go a5 i think it makes
sense in this position to bring a piece
into the game
yeah let's let's uh
let's play rook 88 let's get this final
piece
into the action and that's going to make
everything easier it also creates a
hidden tactical threat
as a hint we are threatening
forced
checkmate that starts with a quiet but
deadly move
think about
what rook 88 does and what you should
see here is that queen a1 is almost
checkmate now what under what
circumstances would it be checkmate well
if the d2 square was controlled
well how can we control the d2 square
well we can do it with either rook this
rook is almost controlling and it's just
that the bishop on d3 is blocking the
rook's control over that square
that's how the move rookie 2 comes to
mind but not immediately because white's
going to check me enough i mean we have
to recapture
assuming that he plays a move like queen
h6 then
rookie 2 is
possible
that makes sense rookie 2 controls that
d2 square
forcing bishop takes e2 and then queen
a1 just check me
it's a nice idea
all right
not much that white could do i mean why
can stop that
if he's very careful but that's not
gonna
help the overall position
he's thinking
i don't see a defense yet g3
allows i don't think it allows her key
to
there is another mating sequence here
that's also really really pretty and it
starts with queen a1 check i'll show
that after the game
why not f takes
well f takes is very weakening i mean
why why open this diagonal up for the
bishop right
f takes just needlessly
and and very significantly weakens the
game
right
in fact i think f takes loses to bishop
c4 check
at the very least it complicates the
game
we can pre-move queen a1 that's the
funny thing there's literally nothing
that i can do
okay good stuff and we're over 1400
short but sweet game
do a quick run through so you can find
other streams where i played c6 here
this is not a novelty this move has
let's see about thank you pair of
trousers for the 13 months this has
about 50 games in the database
it's tremendously rare if you want to
play something more mainstream
taking the pawn is considered best
according to modern theory now there's
many possible lines
that you can play i mean the king's
gambit is obviously not what is what it
once was the sort of principled move is
g5 but this is extremely theoretical
this line with h4 g4 95
i wouldn't recommend
going into this there's a lot of theory
here
the line that i would recommend if
you're looking for an alternative to c6
is actually 97 here
the point is that after a d4 you go
well i think you go knight g6 but no no
sorry you go d5 here
you go d5 here the point of putting the
knight on e7 is that if white takes it
you take with a knight and then the
knight can swing to e3
if white goes
knight c3 that's the main line you take
on e4
and then you still go knight t5 and you
kind of cling to this pawn
and white can eventually win this pawn
back but not without giving up the dark
scored bishop which is an important
piece
so you could investigate this on your
own i'm not going to talk too much about
openings
in the speed run
but you can dig around if you're an e5
player there's many many systems in the
king's game i mean d5 is also
traditionally considered a good system
than the knight of six
well the queen's gamut is a lot more
reputable
but the king's gambit is also not as bad
as people make it out to be it's not
losing
and if black isn't theoretically
competent then the king's gamut can
still produce
uh a lot of good positions so if you're
like a fifteen sixteen hundred you could
absolutely pick up the king's gambit and
do extremely well with it
john shaw has a very good if you're
looking for something on the kings again
with john shaw he's a scottish
grandmaster he has a big book on the
king's gambit
and he's a very very good analyst so
you can pick up that book and
you know if you can read it then you'll
be
preeminent fingers gambit specialist i
don't know if he analyzes c6 though
knight f3 is already a mistake actually
believe it or not this is a mistake you
have to play knight c3
the point is that d5 doesn't come with
tempo anymore
and here
yeah d5 e takes d5
e takes f4 transposes
to a variation of the faulk beer where
i think white is supposed to be a tiny
bit better but i'm not sure again you
can kind of investigate this on your own
but i do know that knight c3 is the best
move
knight f3 d5 and yeah the point is e
takes d5 you have e4 and then the pawns
get connected and black is better
um d3 is decent yeah d4
knight e5 and again
if d takes c4 we trade queens we take on
f4
and we're better and we're better
because white has a very weak isolated
pawn on e4 and
white's got a very awkward king that's
lost his castling rights
knight f6 and we're doing great here
we're doing great here so 95 from that
perspective is good okay knight f6
knight c3 and yeah bishop b4 is what we
decided on
ed3 and bishop c5 is the other approach
as i said
stopping white from castling
i was a little concerned about bishop c4
in this position
yeah ikp i mean
isola an isolated pawn is an isolated
pawn iqp
has its own name just because it occurs
so commonly but at its core it's just an
isolated pawn
right isolated pawns are bad unless
there's a very special set of
circumstances that make them good
okay
so we decided on bishop before bishop d2
i kind of underestimated this move it
forces us to take
castles queen f3 i mean he's doing
everything right here
and in this position i already think
knight takes d7 is a step in the wrong
direction
common mistake as i've
spoken about many times in the speedrun
releasing the tension unnecessarily
right this urge to simplify the position
unnecessary move
there's a pawn enough where it supports
the knight
white can castle long this is a much
more dangerous idea
and here i would have probably gone
knight c5 in order to try to get rid of
this bishop because if we play
95 and bishop g4 it looks
like it wins in exchange but these kinds
of things rarely work
where should the queen go where should
the white queen go
and how do you refute this concretely
but this position
the isolated pawn is a mood point
because white has a big initiative
of course you can i mean sometimes you
need to release the tension but this was
not the moment to do it queen g3 correct
now if you move the knight you lose the
bishop
if you take on d1 obviously white
doesn't take back white takes on f6
threatens checkmate
you have to recapture and white takes on
d1 now technically two pieces for a rook
material is about even but if you
actually look at the position white has
all these pieces these miners aiming at
the king
these types of end games
in these types of middle games the
miners are much much stronger than the
rooks that's kind of intuitively obvious
or should be intuitively obvious
um all right
just a moment
okay so it's a complicated position of
course um it's not totally losing and
that's why we probably would not have
touched the knight on e5 probably knight
c5 but after bishop c4 i like white's
position white's got this knight white's
got pressure on f7
i feel like
white has a great position here so he
played this incredibly well
and he only stumbled here castles now
one other example
of a line where this is blundered
extremely frequently is actually in the
night earth
so even gm's have fallen into this in
blitz games so in the night or the
bishop g5 line
there is a line okay so i'm just going
to make these moves quickly it doesn't
actually matter
yeah so here this is the theoretical
position and
tons of people castle tons and tons and
tons of people castle
and just walk into bishop g4 so
if you click opening explorer there's
like at least four games and the funny
thing is white can try knight t5 here
in order to distract this knight from f6
and then you'll take the bishop and if
you take the queen white takes with
check
but
why does this fail
and this is really pretty
black gets lucky here
black gets very very lucky here
no not queen's well yeah queen c8 is
possible actually in queensland but the
better idea is knight takes d5 and the
knight e3 different kind of fork and you
win the exchange
so
this is pretty pervasive and
you shouldn't feel too bad about
wondering this
and the rest is easy and rookie eight
getting the rook into the game
queen f3 knight t5
essentially forcing a mass trade
and now king takes c2 is good but
rook t2 would have allowed us to
demonstrate
the main idea rookie one checked or
takes d1 and now of course with the rook
gone we can play queen takes deeply
and we're winning
yeah getting out of one fork into
another port yeah g6
now we pick up the pawn via another fork
the last thing i want to show so yeah f
takes g6 opens up
this diagonal i mean anytime you
recapture you just gotta consider which
diagonals are getting opened
so you could end up getting checkmated
here
no need for that we play h takes g6
now one more thing here instead of
rookie two we have another mating
pattern we can give a check on a1
and now who sees
who sees the idea here this is i've seen
this before
i've actually seen magnus i want to see
that magnus checkmated someone like this
very very long ago i saw a magnus game
where he
he had a very similar type of geometric
construction yeah it takes d3
let's see if i can track the game down
if it's if i remember correctly it's
carlson against ernst
yes it's carl synerns that's right 2004.
carlson sack this is actually a
beautiful game okay so this is a
critical position
carlson goes nuts here and it's actually
amazing
boom
bishop takes age six
what's his follow up boom another
sacrifice
knight h6 and now the very quiet move
queen takes e7
now white is down a rook in a piece but
black can't really stop checkmate
the only thing black can do is go knight
f7 using the knight as a shield
now carlson simply takes on f7 and you
can see
white's king is safe but black's king is
just subject to
this huge attack king g7
and now the rook
not on h1 but it emerges through the
other path
check
check
and here carlson finds kind of similar
mating construction
check
now this is a fork if the king moves to
e7
you don't take on g6 and get mated
obviously
you give rookie three check first
then you take the rook with check
but rook f6 and queen d7 check me i
don't think i've shown this game so this
is like the the same kind of
construction without i think there's a
name for this the rooks kind of cover
the king
kind of similar
not the same lead up but still apple i
may i thought it was the apple i made i
wasn't sure
and that's all she wrote obviously we
went for the nicer mate
yeah queen g4 queen g4
we can still do this
queen g4 we can still do this
and if king takes d3 rook the eight
track and we win the rock
no the biggest mistake well white made
two big mistakes the first was knight
takes d7 and the second was castles
really that's it
it's a good game by a good game by our
opponent
[Music]
but you know as we reach 15 1600 we get
to a point where
two three big mistakes really do
make a big difference they define the
outcome of the game okay guys i'll see
you guys later thank you for hanging out
this is a great stream
see you guys soon
[Music]
you